the advice I would give to anybody who
wanted to go into my line of work is
follow your passion and while it's
always good to take advice from other
people don't get discouraged when the
advice somehow doesn't jive with
something inside you by to be specific
about this some of my most successful
books have been and not just I'm not
just talking commercially successful but
emotionally and and meaningfully
successful have been hunches I've had
when I first got interested in the 1970s
about writing about the British monarchy
people laughed they said you're crazy
you know why does the monarchy matter I
couldn't find a publisher for the book
they said well the monarchy the Queen
that's for women's magazines you can't
write anything serious about the
monarchy but I did it's given me an
enormous perspective on life you know I
now look on the American presidency as a
monarchy that's what it really is the
American presidency is the most powerful
monarchy in the world and that's why I'm
you have these dynasties in America of
it just someone's go bush he's sort of
qualified america's got his royal
families like we have and it explains
the sort of intangible intangible
elements in our thinking that you know
makers work and makers take saudi arabia
i couldn't find a publisher for this
book for two years i had to dig into my
savings and write it what i believed and
then what's it if you write it they will
come believe in yourself
you